[Music]
now you guys did a very funny sketch
about uh football it was last season
it's just you guys picked up on the fact
that football players have increasingly
ridiculous names yes this did not used
to be the case no but it does seem like
the last 10 15 years a lot of football
players have increasingly strange names
yes i'm told you brought a sequel to the
sketch where you introduced a lot of the
ridiculous uh
football players you've brought a sequel
this has not been been seen yet this is
east west 2013. and i should say one of
the hard things about this is the actual
names like we said they're so ridiculous
that we have to keep heightening the
names to more ridiculous levels right
and we have to heighten who you know
what the person looks like as well to
just the craziest level so i mean the
last one on this is the last one
absolutely
crazy
let's check out the team starting with
the players from the east
florence state university the capital
like mango georgia tech university
america troy schedule
university of louisville
christmas time business university of
tennessee
ole miss crocodile blip
auburn university ghoulies boozler
the u cartoons plural
jamming jimmy jamie
ohio state university conan o'brien
[Applause]
is